foi gente boa noite e muito obrigada
com essa luz a mel sou presidente do
instituto luisa mell de assistência aos
animais e ao meio ambiente e só ativista
da causa animal
vocês podem imaginar o tema do nosso
encontro hoje serão os bichos
mas não é só sobre isso não é muito mais
sobre ética sobre moral sobre a justiça
quando a gente fala em direito dos
animais é comum as pessoas querem tratar
como se fosse uma luta menor sem tanta
importância mas hoje eu quero provar pra
vocês que lutar pelos animais é lutar
pelo nosso planeta e pela preservação da
nossa espécie
quando comecei a trabalhar com bichos eu
descobri quase tudo o que tinha me
contado sobre eles era mentira
descobrir que toda a nossa relação com
os animais meio ambiente eram premiadas
meias verdades normalmente visando o
interesse econômico de um pequeno grupo
de pessoas e desde a infância enganada
os ursos dançarinos do circo não estavam
dançando estava tentando fugir das
placas fervendo que eram colocadas sob
os seus pés
no treinamento os golfinhos saltitantes
dos parques aquáticos condicionadas
felizes eram prisioneiros
olavo para conseguir comida verdadeiros
escravos até nossa relação com aqueles
que são conhecidos como os nossos
melhores amigos de um lado bem obscuro
os fofos filhotinhos nas vitrines
escondiam a verdadeira face das fábricas
de filhotes de cães chamados de matrizes
condenados a viver a vida inteira em
gaiolas em cannes minúsculos até
aquários sem amor sem carinho sem
afectos e brincadeiras em passeios
muitos doentes muito sem nunca ver luz
do sol condenados a procriar sem parar
somente para enriquecer comerciantes
durante quase toda a história da
humanidade
eles foram selecionados pela sua
estabilidade e funcionabilidade a sua
estética quase não importava
no final do século 19 nós vemos uma
grande mudança na sociedade e na criação
de cães
eles foram agrupados em raças
independentes cada uma delas foi
atribuído a uma aparência ideal um
padrão pela associação de criadores
só que essa idéia não deu muito certo
que os cães não porque os criadores
procuram criar num cachorro perfeito e
sim de aparência perfeita
só que muitas vezes aparência idealizada
oculta uma saúde deteriorado muitas
raças hoje em dia são praticamente
caricatura do que era no passado
cabeças muito grandes patas muito
pequenas muitas raças não conseguem mais
a casa lar sozinhas precisam da ajuda de
um humano e os focinhos cada vez mais
curtos só porque nós achamos bonitinhos
fomos deixando os focinhos de algumas
raças cada vez mais curto
só que muitos cães não consegue nem
respirar têm dificuldade em respirar
durante toda a sua vida
mesmo assim continuam sendo vendidos
comercializados só para o nosso gosto
estético
eu pergunto pra vocês isso é justo
isso é imoral isso ético isso lá e
maneira de tratar aqueles que são
conhecidos como os nossos melhores
amigos nossos leais companheiros
olha gente desde que comecei a trabalhar
com bichos desde a primeira reportagem
que vai fazer sobre cães já descobri que
tinha alguma coisa de errado nessa
história é uma reportagem sobre os
nossos melhores amigos quando dei por
mim eu estava no corredor da morte
até hoje me lembro daquele corredor
gelado
até hoje me lembro daqueles olhar de
desespero de quem foi condenado à morte
pelo simples fato de ter nascido sem
dono ou ter sido abandonado
eram seis os controle de zoonoses da
cidade de são paulo onde os cães
capturados pela famosa carrocinha eram
levados e três dias depois sacrificados
toda vez que conta essa história eu
lembro dos olhares de desespero
chorando para serem salvos naquele dia
eu não vejo nenhum mas foi ali perante
eles que não salvei que eu jurei no
fundo da minha alma que vai dedicar a
minha vida a mudar aquela triste
realidade que dedico a minha vida se a
voz dos que não podem falar em 2008
seis anos depois eu consegui junto com o
então governador josé serra que uma lei
foi regulamentada e hoje é proibido eu
tenho nada de cães gatos sadios
capturados pela carrocinha em todo o
estado de são paulo
mas àquela altura eu já tinha entendido
que a minha luta era muito maior muito
mais difícil e perigosa
os animais eram escravizados massacrados
estourados em quase todas as indústrias
da moda entretenimento alimentícia e de
cosméticos farmacêutica quanto mais eu
descobrir mas eu me desesperava as
brigas eu comprava mais inimigos e
colecionava boicotes ameaças calúnias
viraram uma rotina na minha vida mas é
um caminho sem volta
depois que tinha conhecido íntimo dos
animais
eu jamais poderia ignorar o seu
sofrimento elefantes guardam luto
enterram seus mortos chegou a visitá los
porcas enquanto amamenta os seus
filhotes elas cantam pra eles
vacas têm melhores amigas ela chora não
gosta de ficar sozinhas galinhas são
sentimentais tem noção de número 3 toda
a minha vida eu aprendi os animais
irracionais surgiam por instinto
não tinha consciência de si mesmo e do
seu sofrimento
mas quanto mais eu convivi com eles mas
a realidade mostrava que é verdade era
outra
cada vez mais ficava mais claro pra mim
que o sofrimento de um urso é igual ao
sofrimento de um cão que não é diferente
do sofrimento de cada um de nós
resolvi começar a fazer a diferença
comecei a fazer resgate de animais
vítimas de crueldade e maus tratos
aqui a chery três garotas colocaram fogo
nessa cachorro fazer esse trabalho é
muito difícil lidar diretamente com a
maldade humana mas também emocionante
perceber eu posso fazer a diferença
entre a dor é o amor entre a vida ea
morte
aqui ela se recuperando foi um longo
tratamento e aqui ela recuperada e
adotado para história cada resgate uma
nova emoção e uma nova lição de vida
essa cachorrinha aqui é milagres
ela chegou pra mim desnutrida
desidratada com o olho pra fora
praticamente morta até desse nome para
ela de tão surpreendente que foi sua
recuperação
mas quando estava num evento de adoção
apesar de ela ser bonita e do ócio por
ela é deficiente não tem o olho ninguém
nem olhava para ela ninguém dava chance
até parecer uma família a mãe foi falar
com nossos voluntários que ela queria um
cachorro para sua filha autista
os voluntários logo se apressar em
mostrar os cachorros mais fofos mais
bonitos os filhotes mas aquela menina
especial é uma lição de amor em todo
mundo
ela já tinha escolhido e se apaixonado
pela nossa milagres
alguns meses depois eu estava no
escritório meu marido quando um rapaz
que terá um filme lope coisa assim me
chamou
luisa mell quero muito agradecer
agradecer porque eu tenho um cachorro
com você eu quero te agradecer então né
ou não essa cachorra transformou minha
filha e mudou toda a minha família sei
qual é o nome da cachorra milagres
histórias como essa foram mostrando que
estava no caminho certo por as dores
tanto físicas quanto emocionais os
animais se tornaram uma protetora e
aliviar um pouco minha dor diante de
tanto sofrimento mas tinha outros
animais vítima das maiores atrocidades
que não podia ajudar
até hoje lembro da cena
são quando eu li pela primeira vez a
descrição do test drives de irritação
ocular
os coelhos são animais escolhidos por
serem doses em vários grandes serem
baratos e são colocados no compartimento
para não poderem se mexer
colocam clips nos olhos para que eles
não possam fechá-los substâncias
químicas são aplicadas diretamente nos
olhos deles
tudo isso para que novos cosméticos
sejam lançados todos os anos em 2012
os maiores números cientistas no mundo a
assinar o manifesto afirmando que os
animais têm sim consciência todos os
mamíferos todas as aves o povo e outras
criaturas têm consciência de si mesmo e
do seu sofrimento
mesmo assim todos os anos milhares de
cães macacos gatos coelhos são chegados
mutilados queimados para que novos
batons rímel blush sejam lançados no
mercado até 2013
grande parte da população brasileira um
dia idéia é que isso acontecia mas o
resgate que parou o país mudou pra
sempre essa situação
o resgate de 178 bicos eram cobaias para
testes em animais
eu confesso para vocês quando ocorria
uma cachorra no colo pra mim já vale a
pena só por tirar daquele inferno já
vale a pena minha vida inteira mas o dia
seguinte descobrir que tinha participado
de um momento histórico
as cenas dos cães com os dentes colados
cegos sem patas realizaram e as pessoas
organizadas começaram a pressionar as
empresas para que elas parassem de
testar grande parte da imprensa ficou
contra nós
trataram como loucos insanos mas a
sociedade tinha começado acordar o
grande telejornal da televisão
brasileira anunciou como roubo e os
bingos no trato com os loucos em
consequentes mas cinco anos depois esse
mesmo telejornal abriu sua programação
falando
os testes alternativos do país tinham
crescido muito
depois o resgate dos bingos porque os
consumidores tinham começado a
pressionar as empresas
naquele momento eu entendi que por mais
difícil que pareça é possível sim mudar
o mundo
naquele momento entendi a força ea
importância do ativismo ele é nosso meio
para despertar as pessoas para mostrar a
verdade mesmo quando ela contraria
grandes interesses econômicos
por que essa indústria de cosméticos já
era poderosa
nada se compara ao poder da indústria
alimentícia
as grandes corporações para não perder
seus lucros estratosféricos fazem com
que mentiras pareçam verdades absolutas
eu cresci escutando que o peito de peru
e extremamente saudável em 2015
a organização mundial de saúde veio ao
mundo afirmar que eles são tão
cancerígenos quanto o cigarro assim como
todas as carnes embutidas
mesmo assim o peito de peru e de lanche
saudável de muitas escolas no brasil e
no mundo
salsicha é muito comum em festas
infantis porque a indústria não
interessa nem nossa saúde nem a saúde do
planeta
há pouco mais de dois meses a destruição
da floresta amazônica foi tema do mundo
inteiro artistas celebridades governo
cidadãos comuns
todos se manifestaram contra as
queimadas que aconteceu por lá ficou a
amazônia é muito importante no controle
do clima e aquecimento global é uma
realidade cada vez mais assustadora
não dava mais para adiar o governo se
reuniram ofereceram cerca de 20 milhões
de dólares no brasil para ajudar a
salvar a amazônia
se eu contar pra vocês que esses mesmos
países que ofereceram 20 milhões de
dólares para salvar a amazônia então
todos os anos bilhões de dólares para as
empresas que destroem
parece brincadeira né parece mentira mas
não é
a maior e mais importante floresta
tropical do planeta está sendo destruída
a pecuária nós literalmente estamos
queimando a maior biodiversidade do
planeta para fazer pasto para boi
enquanto o mundo inteiro fica gritando
salvem a amazônia amazônia está
literalmente no prato de todo mundo até
a soja eo milho que são cantados por lá
são destinados a engordar animais de
corte no mundo inteiro
aliás essa é uma outra verdade
aterrorizante
muita gente quando fala que pretende
mais falar mas tanta gente passando fome
e você preocupada com o bicho
quando a verdade é justamente o
contrário mais de 50% dos grãos
plantados no mundo são destinados a
engordar os animais poderiam ser
directamente destinados às pessoas que
acabaria com a fome no mundo e muitos
países onde as crianças morrem de fome
os grãos plantados são destinados a
engordar animais que são mortos depois
são vendidos em restaurantes caros de
países ricos
a indústria da carne não é só cruel com
os animais e com as pessoas ea grande
ameaça ao planeta
a pecuária gera mais gases do efeito
estufa do que todos os meios de
transporte juntos ela é o principal
motor e destruição da floresta
a principal causa da extinção em massa
das espécies de erosão do solo das zonas
mortas você ano é principal consumidora
e poluidora de água
os 51 bilhões de animais que nós
assinamos e terminamos todos os anos
pode acabar nos terminando mas muita
gente não sabe disso porque o nosso país
tem outro recorde também o país que mais
assassina ativistas ambientais no mundo
por isso a minha palestra hoje nada mais
é do que um grito de socorro um grito de
socorro dos animais que sofrem sim e
quiser massacrados diariamente pela
humanidade um grito de socorro os
ativistas dos índios que estão sendo
assassinados tentando salvar nossa
floresta um grito de socorro do nosso
planeta que adoece está à beira de
entrar em colapso e um grito de alerta e
uma convocação de um exército
mas só a união de todos os povos de
todas as nações pode deter a destruição
do planeta é uma batalha diária de cada
um de nós em cada escolha em cada
decisão em cada refeição vocês podem
escolher entre a vida ea morte entre a
dor é o amor entre a destruição ea
salvação
conto com vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]